en vendée les élus et la population se
mobilise pour leur urgence il manque 25
médecins urgentistes sur les 90
nécessaire au bon fonctionnement des six
hôpitaux du département à lui sont tous
les vendredis et lui fait patients ans
se réunissent donc pour demander plus de
moyens je propose d'écouter le directeur
de l'hôpital ainsi que le maire de la
ville
on a d'une part
l'effet de la pandémie qu'ovide avec
beaucoup d'activités supplémentaires et
beaucoup de besoins supplémentaires on a
eu aussi la mise en place des centres de
vaccination qui ont fait un appel d'air
sur des compétences médicales donc ça
c'est une des choses une deuxième chose
c'est effectivement la réforme des
études médicales avec le rajout d'une
d'une année de formation pour la
spécialité d'urgence qui fait qu'on a
connu une année blanche en recrutement
médicaux urgentistes et de plus les
docteurs j'ignore qui sortent ne peuvent
pas être en autonomie tout de suite et
ont encore besoin d'accompagnement sur
le terrain ce qu'on veut nous c'est que
dans tous les hôpitaux de vendée et de
france et de navarre et bien les
services d'urgence et de ce mur
fonctionne 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours
sur 7 sur tout c'est ça la priorité et
non pas par intermittence et et au gré
des des permanences qui peuvent se créer